今天分享加平版海的秀的身體版
加平版水光海的秀
它不只能夠中鐵我們的豆豆壁口
還會讓我們的毛孔變小皮膚變細膩
就像鍋子可的雞蛋涼
我是在訓練分享的加平版海的秀
但是一年裡我收到了無數條反饋
跟我說他們的豆豆壁口真的好了
現在的皮膚變得細膩有光滑
但我今天在分享一個效果跟好的身體版
只想那一版在沒有運作的話的
一千左右
這個身體版在沒有運作至少的話三千
因為做完它你真的會感覺皮膚細膩
透亮到全臉都在發光
心說一下眼裡
我們長都都必口皮膚看起來
哥哥大家很大一份原因
是我們的出友量太大了
導致毛孔度3
那我們給毛孔做深層清潔
皮膚就會很乾淨
但是很多人都不會做深層清潔
清潔泥膜對我們有皮
這種出友量來說是完全不夠的
如果用用那你就不會一直上地口了
我們這套護護流程
這是模仿的還不休息原理
先把毛孔裡的油是清出來
再用酸去梳通梳小毛孔
這個時候毛孔是通常的
更容易吸收護服平靈的影響
再配合像我特別好的食光清滑
就算當雲做了美容怨
幾千塊錢以致的皮膚管理
首先起完早之後
趁著毛孔都張開的時候
用黑頭打成夜是附理下臉上容易毛孔
獨色的區域
這也不是為了軟化表面的油質教證
把這個毛孔的門先打開
當便之後身子的油質出來
我們放好之後能做一個熱噴
倒出來效果會更好
等待10分鐘
10分鐘到完了
我們用一個黑頭產把福套來的油質產量
沒有黑頭產也可以用粉絲蒸代替
這種產的時候
要一直用剛才師傅的棉片
它是濕潤我們的皮膚
不能乾產
乾產很傷皮膚
而且也很難產出來
那如果這一部產不出來什麼
也不用早急
因為我們一會還有身子清潔的第二部
第二部
把臉上的黑頭倒成夜洗淡之後
單手該臉部上這個面膜
等待15分鐘
都不要以為負碗面膜就結束了
這個面膜負碗你會震驚
因為我們身子的油質全都輔出來了
這才是介紹申請清潔會的關鍵
只有分鐘到完了
我們用一個粉絲蒸
做著臉上的面膜精華裂的這個蒜華度
把第二次輔出來的油質再一次清乾淨
那一邊清潔的一邊肉膜部
它是濕潤皮膚
你會發現現在真的很好清
原來毛孤裂有那麼多的油質
難怪之前皮膚看著不幸你不光滑
記得清完白臉上的精華育洗掉
洗完之後乾手乾臉
又還有水療酸的酸類清華
塗在臉上膠製成厚的區域
用別的水療酸也可以
注意用法就行了
那等這個精華臉吸收好了
就塗上一些有收護效果的護膚
我用的這款光清華
因為這兩個精華搭配在一起
第二天皮膚會感覺特別細膩有光澤
那我會先把精華塗在臉上
沒有用過酸的臉下上
避免把其他區域的酸
帶到這個臉下上讓我明明
好
等臉上的精華臉吸收完了之後
再用一個豆豆水
防止我們腥淚過的毛孔發火
豆豆水吸收好了之後
再用一個清爽
部門豆的酸護面妝
因為剛剛做完清潔
皮膚多多少小時
有些受損的
再用一個酸護面妝
來保護皮膚
防止煽車
用一個冰冰的東西
逼一下我們的臉
肉炸完了
所有的人力給我們物理的
說想要像毛孔
那我用的是從冰箱裡拿出來的冰箱子
你要什麼要沒容易
冰盒了也可以拿出來用的
那這一套護理就完成了
它的效果非常非常好
也會感覺毛孔
終於能呼吸了
前所會有的乾淨吃飯
第二天就能變成一個氣泥光澤精
那趕快試試吧